(light piano music)
- So I was born with a
certain name that only
my parents use basically,
that's my legal name.
And then my dad, he's an artist.
He's always liked naming people,
he gifts people names,
it's like a blessing.
And he gifted me a name.
And then in school I
wanted an American name,
(upbeat piano music)
so I went by Alice,
and that's why I have
essentially three names.
My name is Nahre Sol,
I'm a pianist composer,
and I like making videos, writing music,
and just making stuff
about music, surrounding music,
anything related to music.
(light piano music)
We're gonna go to Manhattan now,
and this is where I practice pretty often,
it's where I can practice
on acoustic grand piano.
Okay, my first video was June 2nd, 2017.
(upbeat piano music)
And it was a compilation
of what I was practicing
along with shots of my dog,
and stuff outside.
I uploaded it because I was bored,
and I'm a millennial,
and you do stuff like that.
I don't know,
why do people watch (laughs) my videos?
(upbeat piano music)
I can't speak for my viewers,
but maybe part of what's interesting
is that someone from the
classical music world
is doing other genres.
Because as a classical musician,
generally speaking, of course
there are tons of exceptions,
but generally speaking,
classical musicians
are quite insular in terms
of what they listen to,
what music they expose themselves to,
what music that they play.
YouTube has changed my life completely.
(laughs) I'm kidding.
Oh, that's a great question,
would I rather listen
to music or play music?
I think listen.
I'm obviously really
attached to the piano, but
I like music more than I do the piano.
And I like writing more than I do playing.
A lot of times when I'm writing I want to,
there's a certain sound that I wanna hear
that maybe I'll first try to find
on Spotify or YouTube, or somewhere else.
And then other times I just
write stuff that comforts me.
A lot of stuff that we
go through emotionally
in our daily lives is very complicated.
But even when we're feeling happy or
sad, it's very complicated.
So to create something that matches that,
I think music is helpful
'cause you can create something that is
light and warm, but with an undertone
of something unsettling,
but also hopeful, but kinda
pessimistic, but happy.
You know, it's complicated.
So it's just finding a medium
that compliments how you're feeling.
(upbeat piano music)
So when I am here,
I am basically in this room 24/7,
I just got to the bathroom,
and I don't spend any time outside,
I don't use the kitchen at all.
So when I'm here, I'm here.
(upbeat piano music)
This is my keyboard, a CP88,
I really like it.
This is my computer
that I do everything on.
Whoops.
This is my camera.
This is my favorite small keyboard.
Is it on?
No, it's not plugged in.
I do a lot of videos on this one,
and I still really like it.
It's cute.
That's the most important thing (laughs)
about it, it's cute.
Wanna show the guitar.
I bought a little guitar.
It's a kid guitar,
'cause I wanna learn guitar.
It's my favorite instrument actually.
(somber piano music)
And I remember my first teacher
didn't really teach me anything.
The only thing I can remember about her
was that she had this giant
mole on the back of her neck,
so when she was teaching me,
so you'd be standing, right,
and she's demonstrating.
I was so bored that I would
just look at her mole (laughs).
My parents were not typical stage parents.
Is that what they're called?
- Uh-huh.
- Yeah.
I didn't practice that much
until I went to high school.
So when I first started I would practice
maybe 45 minutes a day, not even an hour
for the longest time.
The simplest I could put it is that
I'm not the most talented,
but I make up for it.
I think what I want to
accomplish is rather simple,
I just wanna spread enthusiasm
about music, for music,
the love for music.
I think
there's always room for that.
Where this will all lead,
I have no idea, I just know that
I want to keep refining my skills
and get to a place where I'm writing music
that I wanna hear, and that I think can
be a nice addition to the
music that's out there.
I think it's an obsession, I just like it.
I feel very comfortable with music.
I feel happy, I know it's
cliche, but I feel happy.
Music is kinda like eating,
but you don't need food,
you don't necessarily
need food to survive,
you can be plugged into an IV,
or what is it called?
Whatever, the, the little (laughs),
something that provides nutrition for you.
So if I didn't have music,
I think another thing like music
will provide what music provides
for me to live (laughs).
Does that make sense?